ازمه ثقه كبيره يواجهها الملياردير
الامريكيه ايلون ماسك مع المستثمرين في
شركه تسلا فعلى تحركات الاخيره للملياردير
الامريكيه بخصوص صفه العصفور الازرق تويتر
والاهتمام الكبير الذي كان على حساب شركه
السيارات الكهربائيه تسلا ادى الى تمنمل
وستياء كبير من طرف المستثمرين فالعديد من
المستثمرين في الشركه عبروا عن تثمورهم من
تصرفات ماسك وطبعا من اهماله للملفات
العالقه التي تنتظر قرارات مصيريه في
الفتره الاخيره حيث تسبب هذا الاهمال من
مالك تويتر الجديد في تراجع سهم تسلم
موتورز لنصف قيمته خلال ثلاثه اشهر
الاخيره وسط مخاوف المستثمرين من تفضيل
ماسك لتويتر تويتر
تسلم كما ان بيع الرئيس تنفيذي لشركه تسلا
الى ماسك حوالي اثنين و20 مليون سهم بقيمه
تجاوزت الثلاثه مليار دولار خلال الاسبوع
الحالي لدعم منصه تويتر افقده ايضا ثقه
مستثمرين حيث اظهر الدراسه دراسه حديثه ان
معظم مواعيد ماسك بالفتره الاخيره كانت
لتويتر على حساب تسلا وهنا تم التشكيك في
دوري الالم ماسك في شركه تسلا بعد ما اصبح
تويتر يشغل اهتمامه
[موسيقى]
عما يحدث لاداره الشركه في الوقت الحالي
يجب ان يتم تعيين شخص ما كان رئيس تنفيذي
المؤقت حتى ينتهي سينار انخفاض سهم الشركه
لذا يطالب بعض مستثمري تسلم من ماسك تسليم
زمام الامور في احدى الشركاته لشخص مناسب
او اعطاء اداره تويتر لشخص اخر حتى يتمكن
من اعاده تركيز طاقاته على شركه السيارات
الكهربائيه كما قال قريب لك احد
المستثمرين في تسلا
بانشغالات ماسك تويتر خطر على شركه تسلا
للسيارات الكهربائيه ووفقه مراقبين فان
الاراء السياسيه لاي لهم ماسك تضر
بتصورات العملاء عن سيارات تسلا
الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]